hey there guys and welcome to part two
of beyond training
so in part one we discussed how bruce
wayne might use
sleep and meditation and sunlight to
recover and to energize himself
so that he can push himself harder in
the gym to get by on less sleep
and of course this was just a bit of
nerdy fun but the idea is that we're
discussing how
you can use lifestyle changes and hacks
in order to push yourself harder
not only in the gym but in life without
burning out and i think that's something
that a lot of us
can relate to the main takeaway i hope
was that what you're doing outside of
the gym
is just as important as what you do in
the gym and in this part we're going to
be talking about
diet nutrition fasting and how these
strategies might also help us to
go harder for longer and to recover
better so without further ado
let's talk about bruce wayne's diet
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so first of all we need to think about
bruce wayne's diet because of course
training has two stages you have the
training in the gym and then you have
the recovery where you
build back that tissue thicker and
stronger this is where the hypertrophy
actually occurs
if you keep training hard and don't
allow yourself the time
or the fuel to recover all you'll be
doing is breaking yourself down
more and more so we need first of all
lots of calories to make this happen
and author e paul zaire who wrote
becoming batman suggested that he would
need to eat something in the region of 4
000 calories
that's assuming that he weighs 210
pounds with a height of six foot
two inches it does make a lot of sense
if you're big and if you do a lot of
intense training and
have a very busy schedule then you need
lots and lots of calories in order to
make sure that
a you have the energy to do all those
things and b have the energy that you
need
to repair yourself and by maintaining
more of a caloric surplus you'll be in a
more anabolic state
more of the time meaning that you'll be
repairing tissue rather than burning fat
fuel and potentially breaking down other
tissues there could be some benefits for
being in a fasted state and we'll talk
about that in a moment but for the most
part
if you want to train as hard as possible
and push yourself in other areas of your
life then you need to be getting lots of
calories
to make that happen but the mistake is
to think of food just as fuel because of
course it's also
a building block you don't just eat in
order to have enough
energy to do things your body also
literally reconstitutes what you eat
and uses it to rebuild your tissue to
produce enzymes hormones
neurotransmitters
literally every part of your body comes
from what you eat you recycle your
entire body
over and over again and the food you
consume provides the raw building blocks
that you need to do that in fact if
you're taking lots of
supplements to try and boost your
performance in the gym and you're
recovering to build more muscle
then really you should be getting that
stuff from your food because the
nutrients you find in food
they act like supplements they act like
power-ups and they can do all sorts of
amazing things
for your body you have your omega-3
found in tuna and a host of other
sources which
improves cell membrane permeability
meaning that
you can pass molecules and signals
through the cell wall more easily and
also helps protect it
you have vitamin d we talked about that
in part one about how it can strengthen
the bones improve testosterone
production
improve your sleep wake cycles and you
get this from all kinds of foods that
are naturally exposed to the sun
like mushrooms obviously vitamins c and
d
are also fantastic for strengthening
your immune system
you have calcium for strengthening your
bones but also your contraction strength
lutein is fantastic for boosting energy
it also encourages brain plasticity
there are just so many different amazing
properties to so many different
nutrients everything you eat that comes
from a natural source
is going to have some kind of profound
beneficial effect for your body
this is where we can end up essentially
chasing our tails though
if we take a reductionist approach i
think these are all the things i need
oh man i need to make sure i'm getting
this latest superfood or this latest
nutrient and you can end up writing a
shopping list
that's 100 miles long or taking a
million different supplements trying to
get it
this is missing the point because nearly
everything provides some benefit
and if you look at a study that says
this can raise testosterone by ten
percent or it can
lower stress by five percent or whatever
that might sound really impressive but
the truth is
that's only very small effect and when
you're looking at the bigger picture and
you consider that you have
hundreds of other things all making an
effect on your mood and your
testosterone
and your energy as well you realize it
doesn't have a huge impact and what's
most important is to focus on the bigger
picture
getting a broad range of nutrients from
nutrient-dense foods
that aren't highly processed and getting
a wide variety of foods as well that's
the best way to make sure you're getting
all these nutrients that are going to
make sure that you recover better build
more muscle have more energy for the gym
sleep better maintain a better hormone
balance heal better
all these things so you want to make
sure you're getting a wide range of
different foods
and it is variety that matters too
there's a fantastic book called peak
which i highly recommend if you're
interested in this kind of thing
and there he talks about the microbiome
in other words the bacteria that live
inside the human body
and they contribute to all sorts of
important functions they produce enzymes
that help us to break down our food
they help us to produce
neurotransmitters and hormones these
rely on the foods we eat once again in
order to perform their best they
literally consume those things and then
produce
beneficial waste products and they break
down things that we don't want you can
make sure you're consuming
live cultures eating lots of fiber and
lots of fermented foods but actually the
very best way it seems to improve
your microbiome is to just get a wide
range of different foods the more varied
your diet
the stronger your microbiome and your
gut bacteria are going to be we can
think of this a little bit like
gardening when you're gardening
you can either try and kill off the
aphids and the bugs you don't want by
using a harmful pesticide but what this
unfortunately does is it harms many
other
creatures and plants that you actually
want in your garden so the far better
way to get rid of aphids
is to attract things you do want your
garden like
ladybirds ladybugs consume aphids and so
by
keeping a ladybird garden within your
garden to track them
you can create balance in that ecosystem
and your gut health
is very similar in short the human body
is just far too complex to try and
hack in this kind of really specific way
so instead we just need to get that wide
range of different sources and let our
bodies do the rest
bio wife with that said there are a
bunch of different supplements
that i do recommend simply because we
know enough good about them and because
it's really hard to get them in the diet
naturally but the key thing about these
supplements that i'm going to recommend
and i think anyone who trains really
intensively and has a very busy schedule
could benefit from is that they are
things we can acquire naturally in our
diet
and furthermore they're things that we
probably would have eaten more of during
our evolutionary history
than we do today and a perfect example
of this is
collagen here i have pure collagen
enzymes that i can add to a coffee or to
some milk
and this is something that we would have
eaten a lot more of back when we were
hunter gatherers because
you get collagen from all the sinewy
tendons and
ligaments and bits of bone that you get
when you eat an animal
and of course when we killed animals we
didn't just walk off leaving all the
bits that were a bit yucky because
beggars couldn't be choosers
these days we cut off all the nice bits
of meat and we leave behind
all of the collagen which actually is
really important
so collagen is synthesized in the body
from glycine lysine and proline these
are amino acids but the problem is that
most of us aren't consuming enough of
these
with the average person falling three to
five grams short of their daily glycine
quota
this leads to impaired collagen
production what's worse is that if you
get a lot of your protein from meat
they'll be consuming large amounts of
methionine methionine is good in small
quantities but like so many things too
much of it
and in the wrong balance can increase
levels of the harmful
homocysteine leading to all kinds of
issues this gets worse if you're low in
folate which again lots of people
are the good news is the glycine can
counteract many of the negative effects
of methionine
and homocysteine so this is how the body
likely would have naturally balanced
itself out
of course collagen is what our bodies
use to repair tissues like tendons and
ligaments and athletes who take
collagen therefore have been shown to
experience less injury but also to be
stronger and to feel healthier and in
less pain when they're performing
hey there guys adam from the future here
i just wanted to make sure it was
absolutely crystal clear
that you don't need any of this stuff
getting protein shake and other
supplements
all can help you to get that maybe extra
five percent but this should not be the
priority and it's certainly not a
limiting factor so
if you don't have that stuff if you
haven't been training for a long time if
you can't afford it
don't fret make sure that your training
program is dialed in first
with that being said i'd probably be
slightly less bulky if it wasn't for the
creatine in the protein shake and i
probably would have missed
you know a couple more workouts per
month if it wasn't for the
energy boosting strategies that i use
but like i say
all of this is optional and extra it is
not the fundamental and you can get
everything that you really need from
food so make that your priority and make
the training your priority creatine
creatine is best known for enhancing
energy specifically for bodybuilders and
those kinds of athletes because creatine
is used to recycle used atp it converts
adp
back into atp this basically gives you
just a little bit of extra energy before
you need to switch
to the aerobic energy system allowing
you to pump out like
an extra repetition but creatine has so
many additional benefits it's also been
shown to boost
brain function which it does by
increasing energy
for the mitochondria for the cells in
the brain because of course your brain
also needs energy
in the same way it's also been shown to
enhance sleep and it might even be able
to improve
methylation vitamin d for all of the
reasons that i've explained
and of course omega-3 likewise one of
the overall best supplements that anyone
can take
also worth supplementing with if you're
unsure if you're getting enough in your
diet
i'm also experimenting with molecular
hydrogen at the moment and the
research and studies and theories
surrounding that just sound too good to
be true
personally i haven't noticed any benefit
myself but i'll be sure to keep you
updated
on the blog another way that you can
optimize your diet in the face of this
complexity
is via personalized recommendations the
simple fact is that a supplement that
works for one person
might be ineffective or even harmful for
another person
so one option is to use a combination of
trial and error but this can be risky
confusing and time consuming
blood tests can help to identify
nutrient deficiencies hormonal
imbalances and other issues
but how do you know where to start well
one option is dna analysis
so by getting your dna tested you can
find genetic predispositions
that mainly be vulnerable to a range of
issues this seems to me
like something that bruce wayne would
totally do analyzing his own dna he
could create a personalized supplement
regimen
to support his diet and optimize brain
function and physical performance
so i've been working with self-decode
lately which is a dna analysis company
that uses advanced ai to provide the
most nuanced and informed
recommendations based on your genes
based on a swab of saliva or a
pre-existing dna file
from a site like ancestry you can find a
link in the description below and if you
buy from there i'll make a commission so
you'll be supporting the channel and i
greatly appreciate it
you can also use the discount code
schnitzky 15
and i'll give you a 15 discount so
recently i was fortunate enough to speak
to
self decodes founder and ceo joe cohen
and he told me how he used dna analysis
and his own informed approach to
biohacking to improve
brain fog and energy and to feel the
best you ever felt the the dna is is
the most valuable data about you getting
the dna
kit even if there was no company that
was doing analysis i think would be a
good investment anyway just because you
have it
it's like you know piece of precious
information uh going forward you know
people
who want to improve you you got to know
your dna you got to
use tools to help you on that journey
you know especially with the software
like self-decode uh you know smart
software it allows you to
you know you don't have to spend uh
thousands of hours
doing the research you can just you know
say okay here's what the recommendations
are let me
maybe i tried this one i haven't tried
this one yet or this one
let me start trying these right we
release like a very
in-depth report new report every week
and we're going to go to twice a week
and so it's like this new this in-depth
report about you
as an individual and um so you go
it's kind of like this uh platform where
to
you know to decide what you should be
trying first
how to prioritize these so you don't
spend
uh 10 years uh 15 years biohacking like
i did
if you took if you take a look at let's
say something like 5 htp
yeah it does you know individuals who
have more
need for that because their system is
you know their
neurotransmitters and is more deficient
in uh
in serotonin would do a lot better with
that right and that could be game
changing
what what is the roi on what you're
providing the roi
it could be massive for me it was very
big you know i was somebody who had a
lot of
health issues growing up my body was not
working well
and i knew it wasn't working well i mean
as i got older though it got worse not
better so
how do you say feel now compared to how
you felt you know before you started
your biohacking as
a noticeable uh a world of a difference
no question for me it was it had a
massive massive impact
i was i was like i couldn't work i was i
couldn't do anything
i was disabled whereas
you know uh now it's like i work
60 70 hours a week you know being able
to learn much faster
i learned um i'm actually in tel aviv at
the moment
i was able to learn hebrew fluently in a
year while
working 60 70 hours a week yeah it's
actually a language harder than chinese
that's pretty impressive again and you
reckon that some of your buy hacks have
helped with the accelerated learning as
well
yeah no question i would not have been
able to do that
uh you know actually this is a very
interesting point
i was in israel uh
when i was 19 and
for a year and a half and i didn't learn
any hebrew during that time
and i was having brain fog and i was
having cognitive health
i wasn't even working another thing i've
been researching and experimenting with
a lot personally lately
is nad plus or nicotinamide
adenine nucleotide basically this is a
substance in the human body
it's a coenzyme and a cofactor that
serves as an important
element it needs to be present for a lot
of chemical reactions to occur
throughout the body in particular
those that involve electron transfer
between cellular functions
this in turn makes it essential for all
kinds of crucial metabolic processes in
the human body
in much the same way that oxygen is we
couldn't live without it for more than
30 seconds
and people like dr simon sinclair say
that this was probably one of the most
fundamental forces in the human body one
of the earliest aspects of our biology
that evolved billions of years ago so
nad plus is crucial for the production
of atp
a desenzine triphosphate this is the
most basic
energy currency for human life and all
life and
it's what we basically burn sugar and
fat in order to create
energy plus also gets turned into nadh
nadh is crucial for the krebs cycle
as well as glycolysis whereas nad plus
is necessary for the electron transfer
chain
without this your mitochondria wouldn't
function you wouldn't be producing atp
and like i say you'd die likewise if
you've got a lower amount then you can
have less energy and if you have more
then you're going to have more energy
but there's many more roles for nad plus
beyond this in particular nad plus need
to be present for sirtuins to function
into a type of protein that carry out
once again a number of crucial different
roles in the body
they act as kind of like tags or markers
that tell
the body that certain molecules are
ready for certain actions
and in particular they help with the
maintenance and the repair of dna
which as you can imagine is kind of
crucial it can prevent the shortening of
telomeres which is one of the biggest
markers
of aging you can think of aging as the
collective cumulative
damaged dna that we experience as we get
older and this in turn results in
less energy poorly functioning organs
wrinkles etc but by protecting our dna
better we can live for longer
and studies show at least in mice that
increasing nad will drastically extend
the lifespan
this has been achieved through a number
of different supplements such as the
precursors
to nad which are nr and nmn
these can be taken in supplement form
and in theory they can boost our nad in
fact studies show that they do
boost human nad whether this translates
to greater longevity in the same way it
does for mice
we can't yet be sure as the nad rises
and falls throughout the day
triggered by all kinds of different
things from your diet to exercise
to other forms of energetic stress on
the cells
fasting can achieve this it can increase
nad levels so can heat exposure and cold
exposure
and we deplete nad throughout the day as
we get more tired
thus nad can also act as a kind of
signaler which triggers a bunch of other
different processes
and for this reason increasing nad via
supplementation or another method
could also help us to once again
regulate our circadian rhythms
and people such as dr simon sinclair
suggest that by taking
nad we can actually reset our body clock
and overcome the effects of sleep
deprivation or jet lag which is very
relevant to this discussion
and this is something i've anecdotally
found myself dealing with a lot of sleep
deprivation at the moment
raising my nad levels seems to be one of
the best things i've been able to do
to cope with that i'm actually
recommending that you supplement with nr
or nmn
there needs to be a lot more human
trials before i could recommend
something like that
and at the same time it's expensive and
there are some worrying potential
complications we need more long-term
studies before
we can definitely say that it's safe and
effective for humans like i say many
other things can increase nad
such as fasting heat exposure and
particularly high intensity exercise
batman's already got the high intensity
exercise covered he might definitely
consider
incorporating fasting into his routine
as long as he timed it strategically so
that
he had the energy in the carbs when he
needed them fasting doesn't have to be
something you do
set time every week or set time every
day you can intermittently
intermittently fast so if you found this
video useful and interesting guys if did
then please leave a like and share
around that will help me out
immensely what supplements or nutrients
do you think are vital for optimal
performance
which of these topics would you like me
to dive into in more depth in future
like i say if you're interested in using
self-decode to get your own dna
analyzed you can find a link in the
description down below and get that 15
discount and i greatly appreciate it
alternatively you can read either of my
books the ebook and training program
super functional training which is an
approach to training that incorporates
everything from
biohacking to training to improve your
mobility your fitness your strength your
focus your creativity all these things
at once and functional training and
beyond which is my print book which is
an introduction to
functional training and how it applies
to athletes and the general public
either way thank you so much for
watching this one guys and i'll see you
next time
bye for now